mike fox was telling me that ronnie
and chris used to flirt during zoom
happy hour
oh a lot but something happened where
they're not uh
on the same page what the hell is he
talking about we never
did mike what do you know about the zoom
happy hour where ronnie
he knows nothing well firstly it's gonna
be watch see how many words i can get
him before you go ahead [ __ ]
see there it goes but no like around the
office
they used to [ __ ] around like they used
to flirt i think there was some like ass
grabbing
and on the zoom happy hour it's fun but
it's like i do i do think this
quarantine is making ronnie just like
the angriest man in the world
hey howard can i can i tell you one
thing the friday zoom parties or
whatever you want to call them the happy
hours i was on it like two weeks ago and
it was an
hour of talking about jerking off
ronnie was talking about how he only
uses two fingers and another guy
was talking around it takes him an hour
to get off ronnie uses three fingers he
doesn't use the full
i mean it was really getting descriptive
gary called in from the beach it was
nice and he said like it took him four
times until he finally just hung up he's
like guys
i'm [ __ ] like in public and you guys
relaxed there were so many
feet away stop the clock stop but i had
my phone up high
and it was a lot of [ __ ] i love it i
think it's very good
but mike didn't say a word right mike
was very quiet and didn't say boo
chris what was ronnie describing what he
would do to his own [ __ ] or
your [ __ ] what was he telling us how he
used to when he was a younger man
oh he used to squirt his [ __ ] on the wall
two weeks ago two weeks ago you squirted
your [ __ ] on the wall
no no no we were talking about this two
weeks ago
why would you come on your wall ron i
was repainting the living room
dude that's where it shot and it's shot
behind you ronnie
yeah it's shot behind me over my house
what do you mean it's like a trick shot
what do you mean
you're laying you're laying in bed okay
okay flat on your back on
in your bed with your head on your
pillow okay right okay
and there's a wall here there's a wall
behind you of course there's your baby
there's a wall okay right and you duvet
so
when when i blew my load it went over my
[ __ ] head onto the wall
wow you know i gotta say something by
that
i mean your [ __ ] is like a 12-gauge
shotgun
explaining it that's an amazing distance
like book shot
ryan has a technique ronnie you should
explain it
he said there's a technique that he
jerks off in a certain way and i
actually kind of want to try it
you were saying how you only you don't
use the whole hand
right you only use three fingers right
and then i didn't fully understand path
that just
that's it you use three fingers legal
will's gonna throw up
yeah he's got to close it and he's gonna
[ __ ] his stomach
it's a pen robin calm down oh so
here's your [ __ ] right this is the head
the blue part
here's his this is just below the head
this white piece right
the shaft so you you're right so you got
two fingers right here one just below
all right the head one on the head and
one
behind it right right there there is a
vein
a thick vein
right in that spot where i'm showing you
where they're
covering the hole where the thumb is
okay i'm showing you
right here okay like a triangle defense
back here
back here okay right there right this is
the back up this is the back
of your [ __ ] right here this is the back
now i got you
so you got one finger here that's on the
we're on the back now okay yeah that's
the top of your [ __ ]
yeah like right on the head you got a
small [ __ ] dude
and then this is the front go ahead
right where there's an
another vein right there is that the
front
this is the vein that's the vein that's
the front
your thumb where's the back
over here over there where's the head
where's the head okay
all right how do you manipulate it come
on
do it just like oh like that okay
i'm like the einstein of jerking off
unbelievable
now if you really want to come you get
yourself a mixing spoon
and you jam it up your ass and you spin
it around like you got a blender going
up on your
on your prostate and i'm telling you i
almost took my neighbor's head off one
time i shot so hard
you mean you mean you shot right through
the window and it went into your
neighbor's house the wall
the wall the brick wall